he's uh he's an asset both on and off
the board and with his style it's just
so nice to watch him play chess
absolutely and here we go
I'm just wrap it
we saw Vincent kind of freestyle
yesterday in a few openings and today
he's playing a branch of the ready
opening so white bringing his night out
on the first move not occupying the
center with pawns he's going to aim to
do that from afar and by uh playing B3
White's last move he's getting ready to
fiancato his dark Squad Bishop black is
doing the same now
see black block this attack on the rook
in the corner by bringing his Knight out
and a bit of a surprise to me for both
sides especially Vincent going for this
type of opening it's quite provocative
in a way
but yeah he's uh he's at least asking
questions for mamajarov that maybe he
hasn't faced too often before
yeah it was a surprise to me actually
because I really expected Vincent to
kind of stick to tried and tested
formulas now follow the mainstream but
instead he's taking the game into maybe
a position where he can control the
activity but it's not so well known
and now with this bone capture Vincent
has a question to answer if he
recaptures with the white Pawn towards
the center the game will be maybe a bit
more static for a while we'll just see
the Pieces come out so if he takes with
the bishop maybe we'll see the center
explode open a bit more directly later
okay he does take with the bishop
getting ready to Castle
very standard very uh solid start to the
game for both players it doesn't look
like the type of position where managero
can whip up and attack there that's uh
maybe one disappointment for us for him
as well
Vincent the great air quality over there
in Germany just so professional even at
your such a young age what what is the
optimal humidity
oh good question do we know that as long
as it's ringed by Greenhouse actually uh
uh I is it around 50 yes I think so I
think I think here we've got a green
59.43 so this is good I think anything
under 60 because I know we had our air
things moved from my office to the
basement flat and it was for a long time
it was like this is not happy 67 get
your community down and I was like okay
okay
some heating there uh-huh so around 50.
yeah around 50 60 anything where it's
green as David said
good rule of thumb we have seen players
kind of uh stumble blunder even when
they've got CO2 levels over a thousand
when you know the day drags on and yeah
and it seems to affect them so yeah
Vincent clearly paying attention to the
other thing's device yeah
and uh it's surprising to me that
Vincent takes a pause here and because
the most natural move is just simply to
Castle the king get it to safety and uh
here we go now a pawn breaks open the
Santa
and these positions I find very
difficult to play because there is no
Pawns in the center so this just means
all the dinos dynamism transfers to the
pieces
and you have to be so precise I mean how
do you massage an advantage out of this
yeah maybe you don't but yeah I was
about to say I don't think you do here
I've not been impressed by Vincent's
opening whatsoever he's freestyled it
which is fine but uh shaka's responded
very classically he's going to play
Knight C6 and basically solved all of
his opening problems here I see
absolutely nothing here for white to to
chew on so
the think Shack will be very happy and
he's clearly studied this before or
something similar Shaq just from the
speed with which he's been playing
um this queen move for example isn't 100
obvious if you're new to the position
and he's just played it instantly so it
does feel to me like Vincent despite
trying to Freestyle he stumbled into
some homework and
symmetrical Pawn structures as you say
Ivanka it's just so hard uh to kind of
find any potential in your position that
type of move as well shows like I think
you're right Laurence he's
already playing for the advantage
anymore yeah it's just an admission that
in the opening has not gone particularly
well with Shaq will now probably bring
his Rooks into the center he's probably
just double checking that the F7 Square
isn't too uh isn't too loose so for
example bringing that effort to d8
9g5 doesn't really exist but you do have
to double check it yeah so we could show
maybe just how things would go wrong for
example if white weights if the root
comes yeah you're right at least you
have to
consider the square being attacked yeah
because there's all sorts of funky
tactics after Knight G5 because you
can't take on D4 because there's an
in-between check on F7 so you actually
uh have to be careful of that and if you
protect that poor environment like
Knight to E5 which is the first reaction
the Knight on E5 is temporarily loose so
there are all kinds of weird moves like
Knight D to E6 here now I don't know I I
don't know if it works it's it's just a
random kind of idea but it's those sorts
of
patterns that you have to be aware of
you know things can get crazy here
Knight takes E4 can you then go Knight
takes d8 Knight takes B2 it probably
works out for black in the end but
nevertheless yeah nevertheless you have
to be aware of it so that's why Shaq I
think was very clever he just brought
the other Rook to C8 now there's no
issue with the F7 pawn and basically
tennis match Pop the ball over to
Vincent ball is in your court show me
something young man I can't I always
call this type of Chess a bass line
tennis exactly everyone is hitting there
exactly from their own aside no one is
coming forward yeah maybe white will do
the same bring us Rook across or maybe
White's yeah there you go
um yup very sensible move again Baseline
just waiting slowly improving the pieces
and now again questions if the black
Rook comes to the square then maybe some
tenderness on F7
it's hard to imagine anything going too
wrong to be honest I guess the White
Queen will just run out of uh out of the
way out of the eye line of this black
Rook it could just move for example and
it's very tense yeah not even sure what
either side is aiming for to be honest
for example if black just sits and waits
just defends this Square over protects
it
how is white ever going to create
anything without exchanging pieces which
only leads to equality yeah I've I've
realized sorry to interrupt but I've
realized David that is your favorite
move in chess Bishop from D7 to EA he
was loving it yesterday as well we now
know your favorite little move that
little backwards protective move it's
funny you mentioned that Lawrence
because uh Simon was also saying the
same yeah and Peter leko so Vincent
Comer's coach
um I think you were there as well at the
airport once after the Isle of Man
tournament he was saying with white my
favorite move is Bishop D2 to E1 and I
did play it three times in the same
tournament with white uh yeah just
keeping my Bishop safe for later I I do
remember Peter lecco in that
conversation saying that he loved
following David's games because David
almost always kind of got the opening
slightly wrong or maybe slightly
uncomfortable and then he has to contort
in a very special way and he manages to
then get an advantages so great stuff
um I can tell you what I would want my
queen I mean the only thing that I I
think about in this position is that I
would really want the White Queen and it
is a pipe dream at the minute to be
planted on the H4 Square
because you often have that as a
dangerous so you want to get here
something yeah but it's not going to
happen so it's hard to get there
unfortunately yeah I know so that means
the action probably is going to take a
place in the center and then it's just
going to be about who is uh better with
their pieces I I've got to mention this
because I know if Simon was sitting here
would be thinking of exactly the same
idea now the move A6 I would I know I
would have played Bishop B8 I thought A6
was interesting now it doesn't work
because the machine the the bar would
have gone to plus four or something but
the move Bishop takes F7 check is a move
you have to consider and the point is
it's a bishop sacrifice and after King
takes Bishop you now play them with
Queen C4 check
and
as I say it doesn't quite work here but
it's not far off from working because
when the King goes back you then throw a
knight into G5 and all of a sudden
you're threatening to enter in on F7
unfortunately black has got to move 95
here and it kind of saves the day but
it's not far off from actually working
you're right it's actually much more
scary than it looks I mean for example
you could also start with this Knight
check
um hitting the king and if the King goes
back the same square we were talking
about
this move we said doesn't work but maybe
you could flick in this night move and
yeah suddenly you're hitting this bishop
hitting the Rook
okay yeah it's really it's close but
it's very close to working
um so Shaq just the fact that he played
this move so quickly
either he's just calculated at all which
I wouldn't put past him or his uh sense
of danger has deserted him I'm not sure
which one but either way let's go back
to the players Vincent right now if he
wants to be ambitious he could
contemplate sacrificing a bishop yeah it
just uh it didn't feel like the right
time yeah yeah but it's in the pocket
right and also white has plans of
oh this is so true to my style I need to
fix it I'm so predictable pushing Pawns
in the center you know step one Pawn up
add another and another one and uh all
the way to the E6 Square I love E4 E5 E6
I think that's a great little idea yeah
but uh ah it's like my calling card no
but I mean it's in this position it's
what you do isn't it I mean if it was
White's move here you would probably go
here forward yeah hmm But yeah anyways
tense tense game and mamiara's played
super fast so far more than 14 minutes
left on the clock I see that you guys
are already sharing your usernames for
Leeches chess24 or chess.com on Twitter
using hashtag chess champs for a chance
to get your performance analyzed by
Grandmaster David Howell later today
very cool so one of you will get his
expert help and maybe some tips on how
you can improve and actually after this
game we will be joined live by a
professional chess coach and we will ask
him a bunch of questions on tips and
tricks for you guys at any level if you
are under 20 100 or if you are above 20
2000 how you can improve and increase
your rating by a lot we're going to ask
him a bunch of questions about that so
if you are working on your chest to
improve then stay tuned for that
yeah I love reading everyone's uh
reasons yeah David [ __ ] either analyze
you you have some big tournaments games
coming up yeah there's a lot of people
that have been stuck around the 1500
level and everyone wants to make their
breakthrough so this seems to be a
common pattern uh other than that you
know that lots of people kind of like
saying well you know it would be great
if David could kind of like point out
something because they're struggling in
the openings a lot of people unsure
actually aware to improve on how to
improve and so this kind of data will be
very helpful there's also a lot of
people who are saying once again it's
their birthday yeah
and David could you please help out
we'll try and get around as many people
yes yeah so uh please share everyone we
will choose someone and stay tuned for
that professional chess coach joining
after this game I have a bunch of
questions lined up for him about
improving in chess yeah and coaches are
important we mentioned Vincent he's had
a chess coach for a long time now
peterleko and I think since he was 12
years old so the last five six years and
he's helped him reach the elite levels
already at what level do you start
working with a professional coach so we
know Prague started at a very early age
right at like seven or something Have
you when did you start working with the
coach David
um I must have been six or seven years
old as well and I think until the age of
11 12. it wasn't always the same coach
but I had a bunch of different coaches
for different phases and I mean after
that I was mostly working on my own
other stuff got in the way like school
but yeah I mean it was enormously
helpful it helped me make those big
jumps yeah how about you guys
um yeah my my story is a little bit sad
actually because we couldn't afford a
coach I mean so we had a family Mentor
who would kindly donate his time and uh
you give us access to books and also
just give us thoughts
um but I I definitely benefited from
hiring a coach when I was in my 20s you
know and he actually changed my
repertoire and I found it tremendously
useful and of course I I did manage to
work with some coaches when I was
playing for England and in those
particular events so that was quite
handy and I mean it's so nice to have
someone kind of say here's your
strengths here are your weaknesses and
also just be there for you and say hey
well done and you actually see a lot of
the top players they take the coaches
with them not only just to give chess
advice but also to bring good mood yeah
just very very very important yeah
absolutely
chess coaches but obviously we
understand that hobby players they don't
have their own chess coaches so that's
why you can follow us for some tips and
tricks that's a good reason to download
aimcast it's basically its own coach
definitely strengths weaknesses and also
helps you you can play against the
computer on positions that you've
actually had in your own games and
improved from there so uh really yeah I
love that feature that you can actually
the aim just just tells you this was
your blunder this was your mistake now
you need to work on it yeah and that's
what you need you know you need that
little highlighter to tell you this is
where you need to dedicate your time
because otherwise there's a lot of data
around there I mean I mean yeah when I
was a when I was young
I have a long long time ago you know it
was pretty easy I would say compared to
now you know there were books that you
could kind of think everyone everyone
had their own repertoire their their own
things and now it was like database
millions and millions of games and all
this information coming at you I mean
where to be frustrating it is definitely
and meanwhile David yeah favorite move
and after yes five minutes away onto the
position it's not necessarily maybe
Shaq's favorite move a retreating move
keeping a bishop on slightly passive
square but it's a safe one so maybe it
just needed to be done then again the
evaluation bar went back in White's
favor and Vincent trades off a set of
knights I guess he's getting ready to
jump into the center with his other
Knights maybe one of the white Bishops
can go and attack that black queen
okay Mama jar of just desperately trying
to trade off pieces but
are you guys surprised that the computer
is really excited about this for white
it still looks like black should be
solid enough
um
yeah again but I I think somehow this
has worked out quite well for Vincent
because once again it's one of those
positions where
Shaq is going to have to do nothing very
well I don't think that's one of his
greatest strengths just kind of fiddling
around and not doing things that are too
active he's going to have to find things
that are a little bit uh
what's the word uh dry if I can use that
you know Rook takes D1 Queen C7 go on
sorry sorry I got really excited because
I think black has to tread very
carefully like so for instance you you
were to capture that with the queen
right and say you capture that Knight
with the bishop I think that's a bit
careless because all of a sudden the
night can come to the G5 Square attack
the pawn and the point is it's not very
easy to defend that horn because after
if you step forward with uh E6 Pawn then
you just
take it off with your night and look at
that Rook it's on the
the I was going to say same diagonal but
that's so not right it's loose this is
loose yeah it's hit by the white bishop
or would you kind of say that pattern is
when it's on like the same
it's uh vulnerable because it looks like
a V
oh very good David yeah okay he takes
with the Rook instead there was another
trap um if the queen had taken the White
Knight then the bishop jumps out the way
with a check next moves the white Rook
takes the black queen so okay Shakira
decided his only option was to take with
the Rook but this isn't ideal either
cause the White Knight can jump into the
center with gain of time I'm not sure
whether you start with this one you
could also it's slightly tempting to
start with the bishop move into the
center to hit the queen okay he does
jump in with his Knight Now The Rook
just as you pointed out your bank
account has to be careful where it goes
to uh there are some loose squares if
you'd gone back to an undefended post
then Bishop takes Pawn again it's a
discovered attack The Rook would drop so
he shuffled The Rook to the side
and okay Vincent
he's basically got the maximum amount of
this opening he's just still got most
pieces on the board he's got very active
pieces now I'm loving these two
position is really good now
I'm actually
tempted to push some more pawns yeah
oh God it's funny how our brains think I
was looking the other way I want to move
my Bishop into the center and when the
queen moves then I want to go and take a
pawn that's greedy and but that also
across my radar but yeah but this one it
is on the cards right because it's all
about the F7 Square which
and it's traditionally weak in all
openings but especially here
yeah somebody watch queen Knight Bishop
yeah and shark definitely isn't this
isn't his strong suit defending these
positions he's very good on the front
foot as we saw yesterday some of these
attacking games uh as we saw in the
introduction today it's only getting
very excited when he gets into gear and
he's just blasting away at you you're
dead but in these positions where he has
to be very very precise he's definitely
uh I of course he's a grand master and
he's a super Grand Master but he
wouldn't be your first choice in
defending this position with black let's
put it like that would you agree with
that David I 100 agree um when I've
played Shaq in the past I always try to
make it as dull as possible so it's
something like this but uh Vincent's
actually got the like my dream like
Vincent is active but also very solid at
the same time
um but I have been able to frustrate
Chuck a few times just by kind of boring
him to death or just by not giving him
the type of position that he wants us
Lawrence points out maybe we could get
the ancient stats up again just because
resourcefulness is going to be a big
part of this game for Shaq now Lawrence
you mentioned it's maybe not one of his
strong points and we have seen mammatory
in the past resign quite early in a lot
of games so resourcefulness
for me that would maybe be his biggest
weakness but actually okay very
resourceful 64 wow turning it around so
all of these stats really can not
confusing but surprising at least but
then again Vincent super strong in
Advantage capitalization that's true 91
wins wow I think he has a plus two
advantage or more yeah
uh yeah he's getting that he's almost at
that point at that threshold
wow he's uh
informed Vincent what can we say but is
it is it possible still in this game for
shock to be resourceful to to turn it
around and win it yeah
um still there's no direct threats for
white there's still no well maybe some
small threats over the next two or three
moves um there's no immediate
breakthrough
so if black can somehow swap off some
pieces anything's possible but at the
moment it's just a lot of pressure
especially from the White Queen the
White Knight the white light Square
Bishop also looking at these stats Shaq
in the video he mentioned endgame's
Way's weakest yeah 70s what is that 75
end games incredible yeah these top
players they're just good at everything
yeah and uh okay meanwhile he moves his
Queens so interesting movement a bit of
a loose Square mysterious Mario
it feels completely wrong can you keep
us worried about the bishop attacking
The Rook can you play Bishop takes porn
with a check bring the White Rocket
look at Vincent he reacted there he was
surprised as well just some moves you
get an instinct right it just feels
wrong or feels loose feels like your
opponent's going in the wrong direction
this one
it stinks this move yeah I haven't
figured out why yet this is a bad move
for black
be a tactic for the evaluation bar to go
that high yeah yeah is it a move that
definitely surprises Vincent as well it
surprises you guys a lot yeah surprises
me and maybe if we jump in we can try
and figure out um
uh the cause of black potential downfall
if Vincent finds a good move so Black's
Queen did jump in two moves came to mind
immediately one you always want to look
for checks and captures first so Bishop
takes Pawn check the opponent's forced
to recapture then you can give another
check I think the opponent opponent is
forced to block with one Bishop yeah uh
luckily from Shaq he can block with this
bishop if he blocks with the other one
then this is deadly Rook takes bishop
and the queen Creeps in to deliver
Checkmate in a couple of moves and this
would end badly for black but the
question is do you have anything after
this move
maybe not
I don't I don't see it maybe Black's
solid enough with three Defenders
um the other move that came to my mind
at least uh is a night Retreat this one
looks a bit odd but stepping back with
the Knight just because of my idea
earlier I want to win this Pawn once the
black queen is kicked away from its
defense and if the queen comes in now
it's almost trapped I guess you can just
hit the queen maybe the queen can move
maybe the queen can survive deep inside
the White camp but this looks a bit odd
if the queen goes anywhere else for
example if it goes back then you attack
the queen again with the bishop the
queen is forced to move and eventually
you will win uh this Pawn
but I don't know guys do you see
anything else because in this position
it feels like there's something
it does I feel like there's something
loose I mean I also wanted to highlight
another move that's possible but maybe
not the most incisive is just to attack
the queen with the
porn
yeah and if she steps back then we can
carry on with a plan of harassing her
but she's going to step forward that's
the problem I'm just going to step into
White's camp and at least now she's
hitting the bishop uh keeping an eye on
this Rook at least here Shaq would
finally be getting active but
um yeah it's mysterious at the moment
we're waiting for Vincent to come up
with a move it feels like there's
something promising
the bar says it's very promising but
what is the move okay I cheated all
right take a look at the computer and
the computer says retreating the night
attacking the queen that is the killer
blow he hits the queen and the one move
that scared me was the move that Shaq's
just played and oh Bishop cease oh wow
that's stronger and Shaq has blundered
his Queen the queen is trapped the
bishop hits the Queen the queen has to
take this Pawn only safe square and The
Rook traps it oh wait does The Rook trap
it
how does the root trap it because I
thought this was the end but the queen
comes out again I think maybe
can you just uh go on a greed Mission
and just grab the pawn with your queen I
mean
okay yeah I thought this was game over
um I thought the queen was trapped but
um it doesn't even need to be attacked
maybe just okay Vincent plays this move
he's just coming in with his own Queen
Black's Queen is offside White Queen is
actually doing something
Vince is just so strong I've got to say
um yeah this really nice idea just
sideline the opponent's Queen how does
this piece get back in the game I have
to say we were really critical of
Vincent's uh opening choice we're like
oh there's nothing in it you know it's
like snooze first you know I don't see
what's going to happen and then 22 moves
this has happened to Shaq there's no way
back now I mean white is completely
winning psychological uh a smart move by
Vincent just getting into something that
as Lauren says chakra hates well in
hindsight the way it played out was
actually quite genius from Vincent
because
objectively he didn't get anything from
that opening right and a lot of the time
when you're white you're trying to at
least manufacture a little Advantage a
little something to work with but
Vincent just entered a very
um a middle game without a lot of
tension as we call it as Ivanka said in
the center there was no tension the
pawns had been exchanged chakra's
position was completely fine Harmony
coordination everything was there but
that what what next what do you then do
when you've got perfect peace placement
that's the art where players like who
who in those positions really Excel
David would you say who really Magnus
Magnus
Magnus is one you've got the likes of I
say Wesley maybe just Wesley ah there
are certain players that just you know
how to just grind those positions but
Shaq because he wants to be active all
the time and it blew up in his face very
quickly and he's dead lost now so genius
and a lot of other players should take
note this is how you play against chakra
huh yeah don't let him have any fun
sometimes players it's just like a badge
of honor you want to meet fire with fire
you want to show you can fight but
you don't want to fight against Shaq in
open-handed combat ah okay black has had
to retreat his dark Square Bishop to a
starting Square to defend the pawn
and okay the key for Vincent is kind of
kind of keeping the momentum he doesn't
want to let the black queen out of its
box
I don't think you can trap it yet
maybe you can attack it with the white
knight but and do you rush with that can
you just keep uh creating threats with
the White Queen perhaps you can also hit
the black Rook with your darts going
Bishop
okay Vincent has five minutes on the
clock that should be enough now to at
least find a way to create some threats
find the right path but still so much to
be done
what would you guys be thinking here
yeah it's
Precision is is key now you can't be
sloppy that move looks like a lot of
that makes a lot of sense to me that
direct threat yeah the threat is for
white dot Squad Bishop to go and take
the Black Knight and when the Black
Knight is gone White's Queen can start
uh grabbing the black bishops
I like that move what can I say and also
white keeps in the pocket that night
returning to the square it came from the
E5 square and hitting the F7 Pawn
just looks like White's position is a
dream I mean it's difficult to find
anything for black it's just the harmony
white minor pieces the Bishops at night
they just they make such a good
impression defending each other okay
Black's Bishop comes out now Shaq is
wow okay interesting move from Shaq was
there trying to give up up a pawn if the
Bishops have disappeared from the board
in order to alleviate some pressure but
now where's the queen going
no she's step one square back to the A3
square or where Punchy attacks the rook
and does a little dance and emerald K1
hits the queen and oh well there you go
right now let's jump into show Vincent's
idea he's just hit the queen if the
queen steps back
yeah she is trapped there's nowhere to
run here she loses herself for a rook uh
so okay the queen had to go here and
yeah as you mentioned Lauren now C6 of
gorgeous little finisher here double
attack on the queen you hit the queen
you hit it in two directions and then
the E7 Pawn is also hanging and most
importantly you can't block the eighth
rank because the C6 Knight protects d8
that is what we call a
no uh sorry I'm talking about in the
position with the queen on A5 David yeah
yeah so I was thinking after Knight C6
the queen has to move I'm sorry yeah for
example if she moves here I mean you can
continue attacking her first of all uh
but you can also flick in your move I
guess uh that you want Knight takes porn
uh the King has to move
actually this position is on the board
is he going to take this port now or is
he going to move the Rook IE I'm
definitely losing his Queen
I mean she's running she's she's managed
to escape finally but the problem is
you're losing the rest of your house
um just take this pool now for example
with the track for free is there
anything better
um
I mean I would be looking at taking this
first of all the King has to move you
can't take that Knight because of the
PIN
okay all we need is the killer blue
where's the final touch I mean worse
comes to the worst again you just keep
attacking the queen
remember that Bishop D4 you can maybe go
Rook D4 and queen takes E7 at the end of
that line ah okay that's clever Rook
takes and then this piece is hanging so
you still have to be a bit careful yeah
so this is the current position
I don't think my move is a good one
there what else
I want a place I wanted to play
something absolutely gorgeous I don't
think it quite worked oh it might oh it
nearly works if I wanted to play Knight
G8 it does it it doesn't it doesn't
quite work I don't think jumping in and
the idea is if the king yeah this is
where we needed to move but I couldn't
find a move to work so that one we're
not sure how would we keep things safe
right now
I mean I'm wondering if you can drop
back for example with the Knight
and now the intermediate Bishop takes F6
that's that's the case and I think this
is Vincent's idea after Bishop takes
Knight check now you take the black rook
and the black queen is overworked it
needs to defend its Bishop if it takes
the white Bishop uh we would end up with
white having a rook and a pawn just for
Black's bishop and that's a decisive
advantage since found it yeah yeah I
mean he's so calm just still four
minutes on his clock he finds this nice
Retreat and the pressure here is
gonna win the game the bar is loving it
for Vincent kymer it's not looking good
for chocolate mom he looks like he's
almost lost already on his body language
we do have one result in round five a
win for gukesh against Hare Krishna that
was the prestigious one they were on
board one for uh each of their India
teams in the Olympiad go cash for India
2 and Hare Krishna for India one thank
you cash winning this battle today three
points for him
bunch of moles the bar is still saying
this is winning for the young German
yeah it's pretty much what we showed if
the black queen had taken the white
Bishop Black's Bishop would have fallen
so
he's continuing he's still The Exchange
and a pawn down and Vincent's just doing
it he's putting it in the bank cynical
ways
it's over yep a win for Vincent kaimer
three points he goes up to 10 points now
a great start for the young German
Shakira momdarov it's up and down he
wins some he loses some starts off with
a loss today but he is definitely
capable of coming back with a mass